when it comes to migrating to google
cloud how do you build connectivity
between your on-premises and google
cloud environment
how do you secure and monitor your apps
well stay tuned to find out
welcome to cloud migration 101 where we
share migration tips and tricks in the
last episode we learned about resource
hierarchies
access control permissions using iam and
the four methods of interacting with
google cloud services
today let's address some of the
questions from the engineering teams
for this let's get kyle back hi i'm kyle
today we are going to focus on the three
main questions that the engineering team
will have when planning a migration
or landing zone on google cloud one
how to connect the existing
infrastructure to google cloud
two how to protect the applications to
maximize security
and three how to know when something
goes wrong which is monitoring
let's start with networking your
existing network architecture and
application flow will determine
how you establish your cloud network
setup and
how your applications communicate with
your existing services
in google cloud the physical network
layer is virtualized
using software-defined networking you
will deploy and configure a network in a
virtual private cloud
or vpc you can run vpcs across multiple
regions
and multiple zones within regions to
support a wide variety of architectures
including
backup and disaster recovery needs you
can also use
a special type of vpc called the shared
vpc to connect
resources from multiple cloud projects
into a central vpc network
or you can use vpc peering to connect
multiple vpcs
across many different projects or
organizations
the next question is once you have a vpc
how do we connect it
to your on-premises existing environment
there are three ways that you can do
this
first you can connect over the public
internet using cloudvpn
second you can connect over a private
sla-backed dedicated high-speed
connection
using cloud interconnect or third you
can establish a direct peering
connection with google's edge network
typically you would set up cloud vpns
for testing
and development or temporary connections
and establish
interconnects for production
environments or to support the
widespread migration
of your applications to google cloud the
next question that i commonly hear from
customers is
i have a firewall that currently secures
my entire corporate network
how can i migrate this firewall to
google cloud the way that you manage and
maintain the security of your systems in
google cloud
can be different than when managing an
on-premises infrastructure
we highly recommend you check out the
firewall and security features available
in your vpc
linked below google cloud is designed to
support a xero trust security model
which can now be enabled at your
organization with our context aware
security and access solutions as far as
data is concerned
google cloud encrypts your data in
transit and at rest
you also have other options like cloud
key management service
and cloud hardware security modules
depending on your security
and regulatory requirements and there
are a variety of options to secure your
infrastructure
networks endpoints and applications
check out the links below
to learn more about the specific
benefits of google cloud security
the next question i usually get is how
do my existing monitoring tools work
within google cloud
if you are using any vmware or
software-based system you can always
just lift and shift it
directly to google's compute engine or
google kubernetes engine
and continue to use it exactly as you do
on-premises
for workloads running on google cloud
you can use a fully
managed monitoring and logging solution
called cloud monitoring and cloud
logging
you can even export monitoring and
logging events easily
into bigquery and run all kinds of
reporting and analysis on them
as an example you can move a workload to
gce
run a new gke cluster and set up some
serverless functions and have
all of those logs automatically sent to
cloud logging priyanka where yet
[Music]
okay let's wrap this up what did you
learn today
we learned about vpc networks
connectivity options between
google cloud and on-premises as well as
google cloud logging
and cloud monitoring want more details
check out the entire guide linked below
and stay tuned for the next episode
where we will talk about
billing governance and codas in the
meantime like subscribe and comment to
let us know what you want to learn about
cloud migrations
you